[Music]
you said you're a bartender have you
hooked up with a customer before um
i have
[Music]
so how old was everybody when they had
sex for the first time all start it was
18 for me from what i understand pretty
late but i was 17 i think it was like 14
15 yeah um i was 15. i was 18. i because
i came out of the closet at 18. so
that's when i was like okay now i'm
gonna like see the world so i feel like
right now i'm in my peak you know
like when you're getting on your own you
know what i'm saying spreading your
wings and
trying to explore in my undergraduate
years since i went away for university i
felt like i could finally explore my
wing or like would you like expand my
wings or
experience next time
and just like explore
like what else is out there as well it
was a big like awakening for me because
i was a very late bloomer like i didn't
hit puberty until very late in high
school and like i didn't even kiss a
girl until i got into college but then
you know i made up some a lot of ground
quickly i was gonna ask about
professions like you said you're a
bartender i would imagine you meet a
whole lot of people bartending yeah have
you
hooked up with a customer before
um
i have i've worked with a customer
before i tried not to though because
like someone like some of them are like
regular or something i can get messy for
sure
i don't know if i want to see
my ex hook up like come up come into
work every day like i don't know about
that what was everybody's longest
relationship mine was like two and a
half years and i'm single right now okay
my longest relationship was three years
and currently i'm not single for me a
lot of this relationship 12 years and i
am not single now i don't think i ever
officially had one forever single my
longest relationship was eight years and
i am currently single in my community
like it's very common to have like open
relationships and stuff like that or
even like truffles and stuff like that i
just know for me like i'm a very jealous
person so if like if it never got
serious right i'd have to be like okay
we need to reign this in a little bit
i'm gay so in the gay community or in
any of the queer community we tend to
have a little bit more of an open mind
when it comes to sex just because you
know we grow up being told that
everything that we do is wrong like
couple months ago i wasn't like i was
the same as you as well ariane i was
like i don't want to like
be with anyone i won't be single because
i like my independent i'm a very
independent person as well but then like
i met someone and i was like wait this
person's actually really cool i think
growing up i was raised very catholic
which i got mixed messages because my
one parent
was kind of religious in one didn't
really participate for
me
in terms of like a traditional
relationship i do believe in that kind
of concept in terms of right now i'm
purposely single because right now like
the closest thing i have to relationship
is just that i've been hooking up with
the same person long term but it's not
um
exclusive thank you but i know like when
i get married i want that to be like
just me and them and that's it
i hope nobody nobody's gonna get
offended when we're right here no
exactly it's nothing personal it's just
it's been interesting okay i think
you're five okay okay um i think you
come from a very conservative background
he seems like a more conservative
mindset in that point of view when he
talks about um relationships and
marriage and so that's when i viewed him
as someone who would have a lower body
count i think there are four
i think okay only four yeah four okay
cool i'm glad we agreed
and i think i'm in the middle i think
i'm three um anyone i think you're two
yeah i think that would make sense and
especially compared to chris i think
you're one
and when i think you're five all right
partially because you're still very
young and you did say you have a partner
that you've been regularly seeing i
think i would have you at four
i really have any great reasons
you chris at three i would put myself at
two and maybe you're one okay
i'm gonna put you at five
yeah just because you're in a
relationship that's true yeah so i just
feel and you're still young so i'm like
i don't know how long you've been in a
relationship but i feel like i could
have cut some time off of you
experimenting especially if you're in a
monogamous life actually i'm going to
keep it like this so four for you as
well go right down the line yeah just
just because you're in a relationship
and i know you said you were a late
bloomer so i'm like yeah you know there
might be some time where you're just
like experiments a lot you're still
young you say you started young as well
obviously you're number one because like
you're like i've never been in a
relationship i'm like okay well that's
something
that's number one i thought uh based off
everybody was ranking me i was thinking
to myself maybe i am number one you're
the problem i don't know where to put
you you're the one
that's not the first time i've been told
before
you said your longest relationship is 12
years
um i think year five because of the
12-year relationship he didn't have a
lot of other time where he wasn't
monogamous i think you're four because
we're around the same age both young i
think you're
three because i don't think you're two
or one i'm too
i think
now i know i messed up this you put
yourself a two then you're definitely
not five five i'm going to go
you
me you
i'm actually gonna put you at like four
i'm putting you at three
you let your wings loose
[Music]
and your bartenders will too so i can
see how you can kind of you can get some
numbers there i'm putting myself at two
i'm putting you at one you put yourself
at two something like
yeah you might got it
um so i was gonna have you guys
rearrange yourselves but the averages
that you guys came out to actually
keeps you in the same exact way
down the line
yeah there's no way this is right
[Music]
in spot number five with the lease we
have sophia
at 13. number two
we have art
with 22.
number three
we have chris
with 24.
which is actually a tie
with aniline who is also 24.
and
spot number one
we have oaky at 50.
choo choo
well i i've i've added a couple since
the last time i interviewed so i'm
actually i'd be second right now
actually
i was counting on the card and i was
just like okay
that makes me closer to correct
let's go
you have to give us a number
oh 27. i feel like i come off as kind of
innocent so i feel like that's what
people usually perceive me as i'm single
i'm a bartender and all that and i'm
just trying to have fun right now so
like i know at any given time like from
week to week it's gonna keep increasing
so that's like yeah all right i'm in my
monogamous relationship and it's not
changing anytime soon you're gonna be
number one and
i don't think anybody had me as high as
three it was just that it was that that
period before that twelve-year
relationship when i was in my early and
mid-twenties that had a really good time
if everybody's having more sex then
we're all going to have better sex
yes practice doesn't